لقد انتقلت نيوزيلندا من مستوى التنبيه
الرابع الذي كان يركز على القضاء
على فيروس كورونا إلى مستوى التنبيه الثالث
الذي تم تصنيفه الآن على أنه يقيده ،
حيث تتصور السلطات
أنها حققت بعض النجاح ولكن من السابق
لأوانه الاحتفال.
كان على رئيس وزراء نيوزيلندا أن يقول قبل ساعات قليلة
أنه لا يوجد انتقال جماعي واسع النطاق لم يتم اكتشافه
في نيوزيلندا ،
لقد فزنا في تلك المعركة ولكن يجب أن نظل
يقظين إذا أردنا الحفاظ على الأمر على هذا النحو ،
فماذا تفعل نيوزيلندا الآن بعد أربعة
أسابيع  من هذا الإغلاق الخطير جدًا ،
كما قال رئيس الوزراء ، إنه
يفتح الباب للاقتصاد متوقعًا أن يعود حوالي 400 ألف
كيوي إلى العمل إذا كان بإمكانك
العمل من المنزل على الرغم من حثك على عدم
الذهاب إلى العمل ، فمن المفترض أن يكون
العمل بدون تلامس ، لذا إذا كان بإمكانك العمل من المنزل  لديك متجر بيع بالتجزئة
أو مطعم من
المفترض أن تقوم فقط بتسليم الأشياء أو إعطاء
أشياء عند الباب دون أي اتصال على
الإطلاق ، يمكن للأطفال حتى سن العاشرة
العودة إلى المدرسة حيث  يوم الثلاثاء
ويسمح للناس بممارسة نوع من
التمارين ، لكن يتم حثهم على القيام بذلك في
جميع التجمعات المحلية وكانت هذه
نقطة مثيرة للاهتمام حيث قال رئيس
الوزراء إن الاقتصاد يتم
فتحه جزئيًا ولكن
لم يتم إعادة فتح الحياة الاجتماعية لذا التجمعات  لديك ما يصل
إلى 10 أشخاص مسموح لهم بحفلات
الزفاف والجنازات على سبيل المثال ولكن
ليس للحفلات ويبدو
أن نهج نيوزيلندا في ذلك قد
اجتذب الكثير من الدعم من السكان ،
يقول أحد الاستطلاعات أن حوالي 87 بالمائة من الذين
شملهم الاستطلاع يدعمون كيف أن الحكومة
تعاملت مع هذه الأزمة وأن
الكبرياء الوطني قد قفز بالفعل
من بداية الشهر من 47٪ إلى 62٪
الذي قيل في وقت متأخر من يومنا هذا يقول إنه من السابق
لأوانه فتح
شواطئ نيوزيلندا وحدودها على العالم الخارجي
حتى لأستراليا و  دول المحيط الهادئ
الأخرى بولا
لك